the textile industry in leicester has
been under investigation
they don't like being watched our
cameras
aren't welcome around here
last summer there were claims some tech
star workers in leicester were being
paid as little as 3 pounds
50 an hour for retailers who buy clothes
from the factories
it was damaging
the glamorous image of boohoo was
tarnished by the claims
so the company launched a review
earlier this year they cut ties with
several leicester factories
and published a list of suppliers they
were still happy to use
we've now been told by a worker at one
of the factories on the approved list
that she's still not being paid enough
she showed us her pace lips which on the
face of it look
fine they state the number of hours she
worked and that she was paid the minimum
wage
but attached to each one is a
handwritten note with a number
that's the amount she has to withdraw in
cash and give back to her bosses
the amounts aren't small she has to
repay hundreds
each month we're not showing the numbers
on the pay slips as they could identify
her
and she and her husband are worried
about the consequences of speaking out
we've revoiced their words what
explanation did they give
for asking for the money back he said
you know i can't give you minimum wage i
can't afford to pay you minimum wage
because prices are very low in our
product how much did you use to get paid
550 and it was after boohoo came
told them they had to pay minimum wage
but they started all of this
yeah it's very stressing you can't even
sleep and you keep thinking that they're
taking so much money back from you
what's happening to them is going on in
spite of a year-long investigation in
leicester by multiple government
agencies
who've inspected almost 300 factories
after such a lengthy investigation by
so many agencies and the brands
themselves
how is it still happening we really need
people to to kind of reach out through
one of the confidential routes
to just help us understand if we've
still got those sorts of problems going
on because that's not acceptable
i think people are perhaps genuinely
worried that by sharing information
the factory they work in will be somehow
kind of shut down the next day
but at the local food bank they hear
from factory workers who say they're
still being exploited there are methods
in place where they have to repay that
money back to employer where they've
been given multiple
workers cards so that not all their
hours appear on their baselips
so it's uh we know that there's the
audit approach the enforcement approach
it hasn't it hasn't given us any sort of
results in terms of identifying
evidence of slavery because factory
owners are getting really creative and
innovative in how they deal with that
and how they hide it
but within the textile industry many
believe cheap
fast fashion is to blame for driving
down prices
a spokesperson for boohoo said we
continually monitor our suppliers and
have updated the list
twice since initial publication removing
some suppliers who failed to demonstrate
the high standards required
we require all of our suppliers to
display the details of our uk
whistleblower helpline
and we ensure that every concern raised
is thoroughly investigated
everyone involved agrees change in
leicester is a work in progress
becky johnson sky news lester